bienvenidos de vuelta voy ahora a
resolver unos problemas más sobre el
momento y el primero de ellos dice que
tengo una patinadora de hielo que aquí
dibuje y se encuentra en una pista de
hielo y sostiene una pelota aquí de
vamos a ponerle de 0.15 0.15 kilogramos
muy bien y digamos que lo arrojé
exactamente hacia adelante digamos en
esta dirección lo que yo sé que eso es
muy difícil pero supongamos que esta
chica es muy hábil y puede hacerlo y lo
hace a una velocidad de 35 metros sobre
segundo muy bien entonces la la vamos a
suponer también que digamos que la masa
conjunta entre esta patinadora y nuestra
pelota es de 50 kilogramos muy bien
entonces la pregunta es la siguiente
cuál es la velocidad que lleva esta
patinadora una vez que lanza la pelota y
por supuesto estas velocidades
de retroceso por haberla lanzado verdad
entonces este problema será simplemente
de utilizar la ley o bueno la
conservación del momento porque al
inicio que es lo que tenemos
pensemos al inicio al inicio que es lo
que tenemos el momento inicial como lo
podemos calcular pues simplemente como
la masa por la velocidad
ahora la masa de esta patinadora junto
con la pelota es de 50 kilogramos por la
velocidad que son 0 metros sobre segundo
y por supuesto que de 50 por 0 es cero
verdad entonces al inicio tenemos un
momento de cero ok entonces qué es lo
que tendríamos que hacer ahora
tendríamos que ver cuál es el momento
tanto de la patinadora como
de la pelota y sumados deben dar el
mismo momento que teníamos inicialmente
es decir 0 verdad entonces cuál es el
momento de la pelota tenemos que esta
pelota tiene o tiene una masa de punto
15 kilogramos entonces tendremos 0.15
kilogramos por 35 metros sobre segundo
aquí tenemos masa por velocidad que es
el momento final digamos de la pelota y
si sumamos aquí el momento que lleva la
patinadora y vamos a ponerlo con rosa
digamos su masa sería pues si a 50 le
quitamos punto 15 eso nos da 49 puntos
85 kilogramos y multiplica a la
velocidad que es justo lo que no
conocemos la velocidad de la patinadora
si sumamos esto nos debe dar igual a 0
verdad porque el momento se conserva
ahora cuanto es el momento de la pelota
tendremos punto 15 por 35
entonces punto 15 por 35 lo podemos
hacer aquí 0.15 por 35 nos da 5.25
entonces tendremos 5 puntos 25 más 49 49
punto 85 bp que es la velocidad de la
patinadora debe ser igual a cero si
restamos 5.25 de ambos lados que es lo
que obtenemos pues que 49.80 y cinco por
la velocidad de la patinadora debe ser
igual a menos menos 5.25 verdad y aquí
ya puedes entender muy bien porque es
una velocidad de retroceso porque lo que
seguiría es dividir entre 49 punto 85 y
nos da una velocidad negativa quiere
decir que va en dirección contraria a
donde al movimiento de nuestra pelota
verdad entonces la velocidad de la
patinadora simplemente la calcula la
calculamos como
- 5.25 / / 49 puntos 85 y eso es creo
que creo que te clima vamos a ponerlo
aquí otra vez menos 5.25
/
49 punto 85 y eso nos da menos 0 puntos
105 vamos a dejarlo así entonces sería
menos 0 punto 105 metros sobre segundo
muy bien entonces aquí ya calculamos la
velocidad de la patinadora que va hacia
atrás de donde lanzó la pelota si lo
piensas un poco es una especie de
propulsión así funcionan por ejemplo las
naves espaciales porque éstas liberan
algo de menor masa por ejemplo gases o
cosas que queman pero esto lo hacen a
gran a una gran velocidad y por la
conservación del momento hace que se
mueva en la otra dirección y así puede
escapar de la tierra verdad entonces
esto por ejemplo pues puede explicar
este tipo de fenómenos
y bueno pensaba hacer otro problema
sobre el momento pero mejor lo vamos a
hacer en el próximo vídeo vamos a hacer
un problema ligeramente más complicado y
quizás puede llevarnos hasta dos vídeos
va a salir de forma muy fácil así que
nos vemos pronto